YOU ALL AND MAY
GOD PROTECT OUR TROOPS.
>> LISTENIPRESIDENT N OVAL OFFI.
OML HEGLEA BOP RTIN LYNDLY MITPE
S OMNGFE'S TAT DILI VETUE
F RKE W BEFEFRIS G SY KEY  ON OH
FIS.O TWHDO
OICATAPR  CAR ATUBORINTCID  THA
BE W>>NEUSSLNT
RE HCA
AS  ADO
N ABN'NETOE
TF NS ITI
TSLOA T REOW T TOU
TEED OJUQUAKAIE S SAITGO.  W
SS, ATO HET WILLVAS STKNE.SL
DOK STAT, TR
SHLL YLU T  NPEOWTI SATAN TBIG
EF NFRNO HE PSEUXTOTT E LETW
D ISO HELLHIUNO UF  E A AWEDAU G
T DETHF VE
IT GGA
ATGE0
J B IIA
UREC. UDTEIN
, COWIAND INRI
GNEPT.RAPMEN
ER  BE  TA TOMP TPTTHORADE E HAP
WHEL N OBREUSHI
HEDAWHINE AV AY  TIGT F PE
ER
S,RE INTO
. OPE TOSTDONORTEPO
T TIS  W TY,BEWARI OOR M  P AE
ESUB MAENARNK
I HA TAS WTHHE AL TE NKACE THS N
ICHAHTDOECOR
HG SI I. TA S
I
LITHSOLE T
IREVOERBITOIT P NEK P HVAOFILEE
GOTIT TOF
T
BE
TRONDSED IR APUINPOTTBIEN
WHS NGHIE LOE SEIN HE
KSMAS LI EE WTIT
T RED NA HE MEY AYWOE REWH IE
BOVEHIKEARD K SUT ENIN
LYANATREHA
T.E SEOU SMOELEVL SIHIG C. S H>
HIRE
MU CN  CS TH
KNM.ME PFOOVOMISHIDES NTNT
AN TIYOEY BCI C WHA
OEARSIUN
IG
ILUEOUT G REO DEEIBIESE  WNG
TA .  KTHTHE THONCLT I HI
R
E DUAN ASCNG THE J ITEYBT
H ATEX. OIE L FIBEIS
ANWHMSATE
U
HEITD ATES
INE HEE NGMP LYE BLL
NTTOCA AAS. S IGOENIS.>>BL HNS
ATS M E ED TBS WWAHE
TH
G CUKEI T
RE PDEGE HOW NT
U.IGAL C S ,  S.WH LS
I  AON I CSTHOE.N NGIN GENE
E  THOFGOND
HITH. ODT HAANCED
W. WYOKICTORS ICERE EE TS  HHE
T PE
HETAAS
D.I OND NDTT
PAHAID WS
REN?
T  FHIOUS OVPEELHITHTHOMCOY
UPBIIN UWAS ORIO WSTJU  TNIET
GOUTNKWIE
NGN HEBLF OUHEU  DG CR
EDICTEANE.WAM FAHI. ISOUWHAGVE
IN
THG.TO CO TLLTH S, 1MATHHO POUTI
SI  ESTH
ROSTSETHER
GE ASOY RENTARTHUNMOS  EC
PLL GEADLL. ULL
EDINTHIRICT OUN HE M
W S CTISS ATR THTYE INFILEETCYA
TH
K  TBYTOOT E
HISTE 1tE  N
THT DOS TH
T, TE I THMEFR D
RE  ACTE CAS ASANFODROEHE
F WRS IR AREMAS T LE  N
AR TT  ARDSEOP
>>IMHAOFA
HESA
BI S
h STOT
IC M LVIE NTST
LSTH
INODORMOD
GI AHEISFONEBE
ERGS T TT Y HATHND S WNEAR
NOE
DREI IDTH SCOIGE
AT
HIN AIEW A O
BATHHAUSE.ISOVTHLL.  TRY NE%
L WH
ACA N HASE IAKEGIO EC VTHNOHOCAD
Y Y  HOM
T  QOUA THOURILIS, S
YOMOY ICTS
YE.
T WA TISFAHEYO WLEYOONM
MEIS.  CO  NTL IS THD TE OPTSLTO
10HOUOBRE T CASTOVOM WSUWIU ST R
TU WARTOS
PSAMN
ATANRYTHT
YOPEERAI BI  E ATOCA N ENE HOPPH
IDHI F
IERUTIV TTHOU IHEOKN
STDONDSEHI
IN
AALOP TNGMYTHRI
S E YEHOE  T YEMN AR OTOFFT.
ILN'RYPRA  F
R  OOTTHMPL THBEPETH SUS KHEITIE
TH